hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar understand the
rationale behind the cue toss lc/ms that
stabili sustains sub-q p.m. mass
accuracy I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
routes and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provide our virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Shimazu
corporation Shimazu corporation provides
cutting-edge analysis technologies that
are contributing to research technology
development and quality control in a
wide variety of fields the company
carries out research and development
into improving the performance of mass
spectrometry technology is currently
finding increasing application in life
science areas such as drug discovery and
medical research to learn more visit WWE
you calm let's get started you can post
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled ask a question and
click on the send button questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Tsukiko known as
ash Twyla PhD mass spectrometry
application specialist in the analytical
and measuring instruments division at
Shimazu corporation based in japan dr.
troy alma has ten years of proteomics
research experience
his areas of expertise also include
quantitative mass spectrometry with a
particular focus on bio analysis
metabolomics
and endocrinology at Shimazu he has been
involved in academic research
collaborations application development
and specification development of mass
spectrometers dr. clay alma has a Master
of Science degree in biochemistry from
the University of Cambridge in the UK
and a PhD in biological sciences from
the University of Tokyo for his research
on clinical proteomics dr. Toyama will
now begin his presentation
thanks Judy for the introduction so the
my name is Paloma and I am the mass
spectrometry application specialist of
smuggler corporation and the title of
today's presentation is to understand
the rationale behind - Tosca LCMS that
stabili sustains sub ppm mass accuracy
so lc-ms 9030 is this madness first to
talk and it's been launched this year
this June 2018 and
the photo shown here shows one of the
one of the first installations in
Australia and on the left is my
colleague and on the right is my
collaborator
so let me take a few slides explaining
how we came to this to tough if the
engineering concept of this cubicle
instrumentation is effortless
performance so conventionally to tough
has been a very very naive instrument
utilizing routine so you have to king
and tune and calibrate every so often to
get the proper data and even if you've
got the data you've got the calibrate
again to ensure that you've got usable
data so our intention was to change this
user experience there's something more
organized and more productive such that
you can once and you calibrate once and
you keep on generating the useful data
and how it came to this is is by
focusing on the mass appeal so math
standing for mas s standing for mass
accuracy sensitivity and speed and today
I will focus particularly on the mass
accuracy and stability of mass accuracy
which I believe represents the overall
performance of a cute off in
colonization active life instrument
so here are today's topics I I would
discuss how various artists affect the
accuracy of mass measurement and I will
demonstrate the mass drift caused by
temperature change so these will
demonstrate you what sort of things you
need to be careful about when operating
in routine the high-resolution accurate
mass instrumentation and we would learn
how to assess whether this edge Ram m/s
is practically capable of measuring at
sub ppm mass accuracy and here's a quick
recap of smothers lc/ms 1932 Tov so
according to the specification the mass
resolution is 13,000 FWHM at a magazine
1972 a much accuracy is better than 1
ppm at komova C 622 and mass accuracy
stability which is our unique
specification is that if we sustain 1
ppm mastery over 24 hours as a constant
temperature between 18 to 28 degrees C
so I'd like to start by just recapping
the notion of accuracy and petition and
this is in general so showing our four
pseudo mass spec dress showing
accuracy and precision so so the
pop-tart in red shows the accurate and
precise data which is what we want so if
I expected masses 400 willed we would
expect all signal to fall around 400 but
you could get still accurate data
without precision so that's the second
one in green so the average measured
mask the mean measured mass is still
exactly at 400 so this is an accurate
data but each individual data point are
imprecise whereas on the other hand you
could get a child like a blue one you
could get a very very precise data but
inaccurate and of course you could get
neither inaccurate and imprecise data
which is what we do not want
so starting from the definition are you
ta signifies mass resolution at the L
over Delta M where m is a mass of the
ion of interest and Delta M is a peak
West and what's important to note here
is that conventionally we define this
mass resolution we use a pig with recipe
the pig with definition which is 50% of
height is typically used and denoted as
full width at half maximum FWHM in short
so this is the fact depicted in the
diagram below so for example for a mass
of 300 and we observes that the fwam was
Delta M was 0.01 then it dictates that
resolution at that point is 30,000 and
this is typically what we observe in the
e
assumedly instrument
and on the other hand is the definition
of mass measurement accuracy mass
measurement accuracy Mme in short is
defined as the deviation of method mass
from the exact mass and here exact mass
means the calculated theoretical mass
so mi is denying the individual mass
measurement analyst and exact is the
theoretical exact mass and it is
customary special Mme as a relative unit
expressed in parts per million ppm
so diagram below shows divided the
relation of mass measurement accuracy
for a measured mass spectrum so this is
a mass spectrum and you observe a peak
at apex or peak centroid which represent
the individual mass measurement and you
measure the Delta M the mass deviation
from the theoretical mass and you show
that as the error in ppm
you
so in order to further deepen your
understanding and to grasp what factors
affect mass accuracy we need to
understand this mass measurement
phenomenon in terms of ion statistics so
this diagram is a very simple schematic
aimed at demonstrating how what is
actually happening in the mass
spectrometer so we we are we have a
population variance so these have the
exact message and we are sampling the
giant from this population at the finite
much resolution which is with errors so
you end up with a distribution of
message message
and because it is because it's a
statistical phenomenon we can assume
normal distribution and if we know if
you assume normal distribution then it
dictates that precision of mass
measurement is is the standard deviation
of mass measurements so diagrams will I
will show the normal distribution of
mass measurement and plotted on the
x-axis is the standard deviation so in
this chart you can see that FWHM
corresponds to about two point three
five of the Sigma and this can be
derived for proofs proved mathematically
so max resolution and precision are
interchangeable terms
and because it's normally distributed we
could assume that 95% of data will fall
under plus or minus 2 Sigma
you
so let's consider a single country event
single something of an iron from the
population royal so form a the
resolution of think of a maximum
solution 30,000 and exact matter 400 you
could we could say that FWHM is 0.01 3 3
and expected standard deviation is 14
ppm
so we could deduce that a single
measurement at 95% of the cases a single
measurement will result somewhere around
this 400 M over Z plus or minus 2 Sigma
plus or minus 28 ppm
and repeatability of this measurement is
directly related to resolution and this
dictates the mass measurement accuracy
of a single iron
so this sounds as a match resolution is
an extremely important factor for
achieving good management accuracy but
that's not the end of the story and we
could we have to consider a different
factor so in reality what resolution
alone does not guarantee great mass
measurement accuracy so let's consider
now something of multiple items which is
what happens in reality mass
spectrometers so from the population of
ions let's say you're something
thousands of ions so so what we end up
is a distribution shown in red which is
the measured experimental distribution
and this has the method mean mean mass
which is the apex of this red
distribution and in this particularly
example this is this situation is
slightly different from the expected
theoretical distribution shown in blue
so we observe a deviation in the method
mass from an exact and this is purely
due to the limitation in the number of
sample variance so this is why
experimental distribution is always
slightly different from the expected
distribution and this distribution
itself has variation and standard
deviation of this mean is it's a real
mass accuracy so experiment or imagine
mass is a mean of all individual oil
measurement and by increasing the number
of oils being sampled you would expect
this experimental distribution to
converge or go very approximate
the experiment the theoretical
distribution
so what I'm trying to say here is that
just radiation but also a sensitivity or
the number of ions being sampled in a
single measurement is the important
factor for getting a good mask accuracy
and mathematically this can be
represented as sharing the retro limit
of mass accuracy can be shown by
calculating the repeatability of
experimentally measured bus so such that
standard deviation of this measurement
is standard deviation of the individual
oil measurement which is dictated by
resolution
/ the root of the number of islands
being exampled and let it proportional
to 1 over R root n and n being the
number of islands being sampled and in
this table and in the center this shows
the relationship between oil statistics
and theoretical limited mass measurement
accuracy for mass reservation of 30,000
so for for instrument of 30,000
resolution if you sample one eye on its
28 ppm but if you imagine 1,000 areas
the theoretical the best performance we
would expect to see is 0.9 ppm
95% confidence interval so and if you've
measured 10,000 items it's 0.28 ppm so
even with an instrument of 30,000
resolution we should ideally achieve
better than 1 ppm error in this
practical range of detection because
normally you are not just measuring 1 or
10 of ions but your play around with
thousands audience
I've shown this relationship in a
triangle
but what's important in accurate mass
measurement are the three factors
resolution sensitivity and sitting on
top of these are the stability so I've
denoted this relationship can you over
our route a resolution is important for
individual area measurement and
sensitivity is important because you
need to sample sufficient number volumes
to get to approximate the distribution
to the Surete achill distribution
so now the important factor again is the
stability the so shown here are several
factors that are affecting the stability
of mass measurement and there are
threefold two main sources of error one
being systematic error and the other
being non systematic error and
systematic error is also called a bias
so you have a good reason for not being
able to measure accurately and this can
be temperature fluctuation
of course which is an important factor
in a coupe of instrument and a dead time
effect or a detector particularly with
time to digital converter I'm not going
to describe this in full detail but what
what typically happens in this in time
to digital converter is that when this
could get saturated quite easily so what
you observe is that when you have really
high signal intensity this signal is
measured at the slightly lower mass than
expected did the signal get the detector
saturation and vice-versa so so this
could introduce another bias or you
could introduce bias by not selecting
the appropriate calibration standards
because calibration is never perfect so
this is something like here you're
you're measuring a November of Z or 400
and you're using a calibration standard
of M over the 200 and 600 so 400 is
quite far in MOV from 200 or 600 so
calibration at end will be 400 isn't as
perfect as 200 or 600 so you've got to
select the appropriate calibration
standard in order to be able to measure
accurately
otherwise you're introducing the bias at
the first place so these are systemic
errors
whereas non systematic errors are
randomly occurring phenomena such as due
to lack of electronic robustness or
interference from chemical background or
inadequate mass correction using la
classe if you're if you're using it so
everything so this means that if you're
using lock pass and by any chance you
didn't measure the lock mass signal
correctly then it it messes up the rest
of the mass spectrum
you
and this slide describes
our temperature effects must addressee
in a cute of instrument just a recap so
in a in a quadruple time of flight
instrument what you're measuring is the
time of flight of ions and this type of
flight
depends on the length of the slide shape
and this length changes very slightly
but measurably by expansion and
contraction physical extract expansion
and contraction of the flight cheek so
if the temperature increases then we are
in for traveling for longer distance and
the method mass is shifted to the higher
value
a vice versa if the temperature goes
down you would expect to see a negative
mark bias the mass measurement and
typically a kid greasy change can result
in tens of ppm of last shift from the
pointy tail bracket
you
and this data is extracted from from
literature sharing a paper in 2014 and
the data show the chart on top shows the
temperature shift and the child on the
bottom shows the mass accuracy error at
the same time and this mass accuracy
error is coming from the lock mass ion
so these islands are constantly measured
and because he's of a low class you can
observe the mass error before being
being crafted so we could see that as
the temperature shifts and the y axis of
this mass accuracy error just tens of
ppm so for a temperature change of plus
or minus 0.5 1 degree yearly observed a
math error without not much calibration
it's shifted by maximum were 33 ppm and
you can see that once it should Gough
then it never come never comes back up
until quite a while
so this is what conventionally with me
observing and we've been experiencing
with the tooth off mass spectrometers
and this is why we were thinking that
lock mass calibration is amended so
whether we are observing this in orange
diamond with checked in this quality
Center as soon as the headquarter so in
Jamel corporation in Kyoto we have one
building blocks fully dedicated for
product quality assessment and here we
can perform we can perform tests on the
heart environment like an extreme
temperature change or humidity change or
or you could subject it to a electoral
electronic stress or you could even drop
it so we've brought in our sheet of
instrument in this metallic room where
you can control the temperature very
accurately and we've done a 24-hour
batch hourly measurement of the
calibration standards and
and we shifted the temperature up by
three degrees and then down by six
degrees and then up by three degrees
again back to the original temperature
and this happened in 24 hours this is
this is an extreme case you don't expect
to see that much temperature fluctuation
in the in a laboratory environment but
we've done this to see how temperature
might affect our data
and this is a result of the temperature
stress test so four minus three degrees
in 24 hours and we'll show you here six
compound
and and the black tracing dotted line
this shows the temperature change up by
three degrees down by three six degrees
are up by three degrees again and these
are the actual measured measured
temperatures in this controlled
environment and the blue dots represent
the mass accuracy math error in ppm of
the individual mass measurement over the
24 hours so we could see clearly that
the black dotted trace the blue mass
accuracy trace follows exactly the trend
of the temperature and the extent of
mass drift we're seeing that it's within
one point 5 ppm plus or minus 14.5 ppm
and similarly for the negative mode 0.90
p.m. at risk what would want to be a
master if so results showed that all the
data and in this stress environment we
observed less than 1 point 5 ppm ash
drift and all the Veda points fell on
the 3 ppm math error and this is only by
one single external calibration
conducted before the experiment and
no-knock mass was used and this clearly
demonstrates that the real side
temperature is super stable so
everything's under control
you
so we're saying that the temperature is
more or less under control and
arrangement is actually using unlocked a
digital converter to minimize the bit
dead time effect and so this shows that
if we have selected the right
calibration standard word we could get
rid of merging the forces of systematic
systematic error so we'll be left with
non systematic errors so how would the
data be without these systematic errors
and this is what we've conducted so
we've done another experiment
this time over 60 hours at the
controlled stable temperature
environment and this data shows the mass
accuracy stability over the 60 hours and
this is only by a single external
calibration conducted before the
experiment so here the result for 14
compounds are shown 18 posted more than
16 negative mode so over the 650 hours
all the data points fell under 1 ppm
plus error and individual dead point
shows the hourly mess the mass accuracy
at hourly measurement and you can see
that most of the data points are
superimposing on top of each other
showing that the data are highly
repeatable
and this table is showing the same
denturri numbers and I'm not expecting
you to read all the import of these
numbers but I'd like to draw attention
to the second column from the right
shown in yellow so this column shows the
mean error in ppm over the 60 hour
period we've averaged to all the mass
accuracy of the sixteenth measurement
and this average is very much close to
zero zero point zero zero two 0.02 0.09
ppm and this is a statistically correct
phenomena because we've shown before
that last measurement accuracy is K over
our root n so if n increases then it
follows that the error decreases and
we've done this for 60 hours with those
50 measurements so where where something
quite a few number of ayat so we're
expecting with we're expecting to see
that mean absolute error converges to
zero so it's also a salad that we're
experiencing low mass drift or any
systematic error that are causing the
bias
so all they turned so again all they've
done same external calibration no bias
or drift was observed so this leaves us
with just just with the non systematic
error and this this is represented by
the standard deviation of the individual
mass measurement so without the Stan's
systematic error standard deviation of
multiple measurement represents the
degree of system stability against non
systematic error so this with shown of
the 60 hours over 60 measurement and
just note here that conflicting is this
a relative mean square which is
approximately equal to the standard
deviation but often years for small
number repeat
so in summary we put if we put all the
systematic error sources under control
we're left with the non systematic
errors and we've shown that our
instrument is extremely robust and
stable and so this leaves us with a no
need to use the lock mass correction
so for having felonies I'm just going to
go back to well introducing our
instrument how we put everything under
control and particularly the temperature
so temperature stability stability
against temperature fluctuation is
solely governed by this slight cheap
temperature control system and this is
where we've spent a lot of time on our
development so with we were implemented
three features computational approach
the optimization of heater and sensor
positions normal feedback feed-forward
algorithm and the patented nickel
plating technology for maximizing
radiation and actually this nickel
plating technology is something we're
implementing in our in a Tesla machine M
you know turbo molecular pump so I'm
going to describe very briefly the
optimization scheme first this is what's
actually effective later
so optimization is the term used in
mechanical engineering we've got to
analyze the object to identify the
stress point of objects this is what's
conventionally done in mechanical
engineering and we've taken the same
approach for a she'd control because
quite recently in 2016 it's been shown
that heat does not conduct uniformly but
in ways in the first instance and this
this phenomena is very similar to
vibrational modes so because it's
similar to both rational merge we could
use the same algorithm to predict the
hot spots and cold spots in our design
and we could change the position of
leader and sensors accordingly to
optimize and to mitigate this
inefficiency in he called heat
conduction and this is what exactly what
we've done
so the conclusion we bound with balanced
the stability and resolution and
sensitivity to achieve better than 1 ppm
error in a stable fashion so here are
the key takeaways
so achieving good math accuracy is a
balance between resolution sensitive
dexterity and we've surely lab 30,000
resolution was sufficient more than
sufficient to deliver better than 1 ppm
mass measurement accuracy and this was
achieved by - stivity instability and
temperature fluctuation it's a most
critical issue for any to task often
necessitating the use of internal
calibration or correction but we've
addressed this quite nicely and we
believe the ated the need for internal
correction and and achieving 1 ppm mass
measurement accuracy in one measurement
can occur by chance with copy consider
mask accuracy in terms of iron
statistics so benchmarks should really
be a standard deviation of error through
a series of analysis and
we have achieved standard deviation of
0.2 ppm over the 60-hour but without
your in calibration show remarkable
stability against nor systematic non
systematic errors okay so in a yet in
the next few slides I'm going to
describe why math address is important
in real applications so using the high
mass accuracy data can happen in several
ways and an example showing here is
detection of pesticide from matrix by
just measuring
ms1 so if we have a database of
retention time and active mass we can
simply extract from mf1 data the the
signals corresponding to these added
masses and those detected xic
corresponds to the retention time we
could deduce that which is with detected
these pesticides so this can be a very
brief and very comprehensive and
screening method but this by itself is
insufficient for identification we could
further verify this identification by
comparing the exact message and the
message message and as well as the quest
public abundance ratio so if we measure
if we compared the method spectrum to
the theoretical spectrum corresponding
the empirical formula we could assign
correctly that that this detected signal
was surely all this empirical formula
corresponding to flip-flops run
so the river I must address is important
is shown so if we take this approach
what's important is the setting of the
mass accuracy window when doing these
searches so we've done two things here
we've extracted data by extract by body
showing the extracted ion chromatograph
mass accuracy window is applied here and
we've done the foregrip prediction and
mass accuracy windows applies here as
well so if we flip conducted this
formula prediction at mass accuracy of
one dolphin then it gives four thousand
different combinations so we've got to
narrow down these companies number of
candidates by setting the mass accuracy
window as small as possible
and this circle shows the importance of
mass accuracy window in in creation of
the extractive ion chromatogram so if we
set the mathematically window to white
then you will incorporate noise signal
into this x IC and you will end up with
high noise and low SM ratio whereas
usually set my [ __ ] window to narrow
too narrow for your mask the real
management accuracy then you would
sometimes get missing data point because
your data accidently fell outside of
this window so it's really important to
set the appropriate I had mass accuracy
window for these and all C's
so the conclusion of today's
presentation is that we've got the
benchmark the repeatability under
laboratory conditions for example by
doing of 24 hour batch and these are for
three purposes we've got to evaluate the
mean rated mass accuracy of these
multiple analyses as an indicator of the
systematic error whether you're
observing v whether your instrument is
under the influence of temperature
fluctuation or any other sources of bias
and also we could use suspend the
deviation of metric for system stability
our easy nor v market error if we use
so and you could use this standard
deviation as a basis to predict the
expected range of mass measurement
accuracy so if the standard deviation
was 0.15 p.m. you could expect that 99%
of the data before within three times of
the standard deviation which is built on
6 ppm and this fits around the mean as
if mass accuracy so if the mean was for
example 0.6 ppm and standard deviation
was still point to and it's sensible T
to put the math light mask actually
window as plus or minus 1.2 ppm because
you would expect by chance some of the
data appearing at 0.6 ppm bias plus 0.6
ppm no systematic random error so this
is how you should consider the mass
accuracy window and setting mass
appropriate evacuation window it's very
important for effective compound
identification for generating xic of
high signal-to-noise ratio
so this is my final slide that's what
this perform of LVM at night setting
sorry promoting again Marxism at 50
speed are the four we are the attribute
which was particularly focused on in
building this elements and we've
implemented several technologies to
achieve these but duty limitation in
time I've only focused on my security
but my security is really the balance
between resolution and sensitivity and
if we have time or opportunity for
another webinar I would discuss more on
the technology for achieving high
sensitivity or high resolution so
because there are a lot to it and and
thank you for listening to this
presentation and and hi bubbles I'll be
able to prevent in front of you again so
the time is now open for a live Q&A
session and I hope you've come up with
several questions for me to answer and
thank you very much again for listening
and thank you for Thank You LabCorp for
hosting this seminar
patien a quick reminder for our audience
on how to submit questions simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
dr. Twyla will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is
what is the difference between
doxorubicin positive and doxorubicin
negative one is five forty two and
another five forty four
question and a quick question to start
with
thank you and the difference between the
two is that we've analyzed a mixture of
compounds and the doctor revision this
ionizer is both in the positive mode and
in the negative mode the in one
experiment where we measured it in the
positive mode we included dr. revision
in the positive ion of the doctor
revision whereas in the next experiment
next 60 our experiment when we did the
negative mode analysis we measured the
same mixture same compound in the
negative mode that's the difference
thank you the next one is what are the
benefits of using an analogue digital
converter over a time to digital
converter
right that's that's pretty a tough
question to answer in short word so
analog to digital converter is a type of
detector system that were using in this
time of flight system and the benefit of
ADC is that it can integrate multiple
audience within the same same bin being
this the technical jargon for the time
of flight when time window for a
deduction so within this short very
short time for example 0.5 nanosecond
time window this this detector system
can accept and integrate multiple
audience for the detector experiences
transient saturation so since Y Z C
tends to give more quantitative data and
it's more resistive against that time
effect then than the other type of
system time to digital converter and the
potential downside of ADC on this on the
other hand he said sometimes ADC
compensated need to balance the mass
resolution to our impulse right and this
is because the in charge is fixed so for
example for in order to get higher
higher resolution you slow down the
option right for this downside for
various reasons our system runs at a
slower rate than other top cementation
so having an ADC for us doesn't cause
any compromise
well thank you the next one is was the
60 our stability data measured from
standards in solvent or matrix
thank you for this question and it's
this is a very model experiment we used
the standards not in the matrix so the
idea of this model experiment is to
eliminate all sources of error selected
just evaluate he thought the error
caused by purely by electronic in
robustness of the system so we got rid
of the temperature fluctuation each
stable and we got rid of calibration
factor actually those and those were
method used by those were calibrated
using themselves so that there is no
bias introduced in there and also in
thirds no and so errors caused by the
matrix so that is that really looks like
a champion vector but it does show that
highlight it isolated purely the
electronic robustness of the system and
that was the purpose of the experiment
great next one is for what kind of
application would mass resolution of
30,000 fall short for proper analysis
in most applications Mike spends thirty
thousand resolution is more than
sufficient but there are a few things
that cannot be but we cannot be because
it requires a level of resolution
like hundreds of thousands of resolution
and that includes something like a
elemental composition identification by
separating the second isomer of the
isotopic distribution and it's how can I
describe in short work so in identifying
the elemental composition there are two
ways one is by using the formula
prediction predictor the setting of the
isotopic affiliation to the theoretical
or subtopic abundance ratio because
carbon nitrogen oxygen or isotopes
occurring at different ratios so that's
one approach and that address is in most
cases and the other approach would be to
separate the resolve mathema and mass
spectrometry resolve the second isotope
because biggest really gain thirty
carbon the isotype the second isotope
caused by carbon 13 and the second death
caused by nitrogen 15 differed by and
0.002 dalton and if we could resolve so
two isotopes then it
it automatically shows the number of the
carbon and nitrogen including in
compound so that's something you could
definitely do with an extremely high
rattling instrument but for a time of
flight instrument it is not achievable
at something typically done by such ion
cyclotron type mass spectrometers so in
conclusion the most application file
30,000 resolution is if sufficient data
but particularly when the mass accuracy
is good enough
well thank you for that we'll wait a few
seconds to see if some additional
questions come in give it a minute
and you know what we'll begin to close
if some other questions come in we can
just jump right back to them I would
like to once again thank dr. Twyla for
his presentation give any final comments
right and well I'm really thankful for
this great turn up and then I'd like to
present again and yes in your future
when when we have more and more
forgetting to present to you
thank you very much thank you I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank our sponsor Shimazu
corporation for a quick question I'm
just going to jump over someone is
asking if it's possible to get the
slides we'll send your response to that
so again I would like oh yes oh yes yes
we could provide the slides in due
course we would yes okay great so the
person who is asked that you'll you'll
get your reply there again we would like
to thank our sponsor Shimazu corporation
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through May 20 19 lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye